[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down the Black Mirror episode
lock Henry a true crime Thriller this
actually got name drop when Joan was
flicking through stream Berry like Henry
the Scottish murder thing can't really
do another True Crime the service also
pops up later on and the entry comes
with a big twist at the end that really
elevates the episode Jon is awful really
came with a theme that Netflix was
morally bankrupt and there's a lot to
talk about in this one too throughout
this video we're gonna be going through
it all discussing all the Easter eggs
and the true meaning behind that ending
heavy spoilers ahead so if you haven't
had a chance to check it out then check
out now we'll also be doing breakdowns
in all the episodes in the show so make
sure you subscribe to never miss a beat
without the way huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into lock
Henry
foreign
I want to go over the Black Mirror
Easter eggs and callbacks first before
we get into the plot itself there's
several nods to the entry and at one
point we see Michael's smart unveiling a
robot dog device that comes from that
episode this is for the Met police and
this confirms that they were used by the
authorities initially Michael Smart's
name appears on a newspaper clipping as
well which mentions tiply both of these
appeared in Demon 79 and at The Barbers
we hear about the documentary stuff for
the children centered around tipley
there's also an article on a newspaper
unveiling one of the metal head dogs
which says that it was Unleashed in
London this might be a reach yeah but
that could be a not to American Werewolf
in London which also gets its own nod
coming later on either way the newspaper
is clearly talking about the Mark 1 dog
which explains why it looks slightly
different to the ones seen in the
episode we also get an Easter egg that
ties in directly with the episode play
test as there's mention of a US tourist
being found dead at Sado Jammu HQ
several of the shows shown in Joan of
all four characters cross as well
including the San Gina para documentary
and the one about Michael callow the
caloyers appears as opposed to when the
sun Junipero ones entitled euthanasia
inside project Junipero this is an odd
to Kelly choosing to end their own life
at the end of the entry and be uploaded
to live forever in the server now a
headline on the Scottish Daily Mail
reads whatever happened to Michael
callow now he runs a zoo this is a nice
little carryover from him having sex
with a pig on TV and the guys got on to
get knee-deep in animals now we also
learned about the Waldo movement which
is romped up to political victory in
Italy Waldo appears as a sticker on the
back of Davis's laptop and there's also
one from turkishov from Black Mirror
bandersnatch Colin Rittman was a
character in that with him also getting
his own streamberry show in episode 1.
we find out from the newspaper that he's
gone missing and I hope you stay safe
Colin make sure you make the right
choices now his laptop back is where
they do a lot of the Easter eggs with us
getting the symbol from my bear on it
and also the eye from the episode
Archangel anyway we begin with Pierre
and her boyfriend Davis traveling out to
his mother Janet to work on an
independent film this is about someone
that stops people stealing eggs that
will probably not be viewed by anyone
and spoilers for it he travels into the
Multiverse which is where he meets
Egghead from Batman 66. anyway things
seem dull and desolate but Piers ears
prick up when we discovered that there
was a string of brutal murders that
happened in the area seemingly all
carried out by a man named Ian Adar
people have stayed away from the area
due to the painful memories realizing
that they can turn this into a true
crime documentary they're tempted by the
prophet and fame that they can get off
the back of it not much like the first
entry in the season this episode feels
like it's coming on a lot of things that
Netflix seems to do in case you missed
that video we touched upon how things
like making a murderer and so on were
were big successes for the streamers
that made people millionaires however
those in front of the camera completely
had their lives wrecked and the
documentaries likely unheard things that
those involved didn't really want people
to know now we discovered that Davis's
mother and father were involved in the
murders too and I got a lot of Fred and
Rose West Vibes coming from this episode
in case you don't know this was a killer
couple that murdered several people and
they got away with it for years and
years and years both were involved with
sordid stuff and Rose's sexual exploits
were splashed all over the front page if
you're not from England then you
probably haven't heard of them but their
crimes have been documented in several
shows and documentaries that's where my
mind went with this and we know that the
pair also had several children as well
Fred killed one of these but the other
two of course would have found
themselves in a similar situation to
Davis one of the children grew up to
commit several abusive crimes himself
and it's a pretty messed up Story Once
you read through the entire thing now
because of this though several show
producers have flocked to the story to
try and turn the tragedy into a
commodity Davis is given the fame and
riches he was initially seeking but the
story is kind of taken away from him
come the end of the entry it's now in
the public domain and those producers
can constantly keep making documentaries
shows and movies about it he's
metaphorically shoved out of it come the
end of the episode with him having to
stare at her producers back as she talks
about plans for the future this is to
the person who could potentially play
Pierre who dies towards the end after
discovering the truth this shows that
the story is no longer under his control
and it's now in the hands of those who
are solely after money now though he
gets up after he isn't happy and it's
kind of like a wish coming true for him
with all the downsides of it someday
this guy with polishing bath doesn't
forgetting about us probably shakes he
used to cut about me the map there
itself is a mask and now David must put
on a happy face and pretend to be
enthusiastic this ends up also bringing
back business to the local pub but you
have to ask yourself what it really cost
now what the episode does brilliantly is
that it shows both sides of the argument
when it comes to making this stuff the
characters of course feel like it's
important to tell the story but they
also wrestle with the backlash that
comes with it Pierre sells it that Davis
and his mum can finally tell a story but
there's death definitely this idea that
appears using the victims for our own
personal gain people will often argue
that you shouldn't be bringing up the
dead like this and using them as a way
to get Fame and Fortune especially as
people went through some of the most
horrendous things imaginable all the bad
things in this episode happen from the
characters being unable to help
themselves from digging up the past in
their never-ending quests to make the
True Crime documentary they even put
words in a Stew's mouth and they make
sure he says certain things so the
documentary's juicier there's a scene in
which they're singing the car joking
about the murders and this causes Davis
to crash the car when he joins in could
have been fatal and them clearly
laughing and joking has an almost car
make response that causes them to almost
lose their lives I think thematically
that it works really well and you can
say this episode's basically curiosity
killed the cat now being a YouTuber I've
run into controversy myself if I've
covered a certain movie with either
let's say a problematic actor or a
problematic director some people just
flat out tell me they're unsubscribing
because I shouldn't be covering it and
though it's not the same as a murder
sensitive subjects will plain put some
people off and that's me not getting
angry at them either everyone has their
own principles and what they think is
okay to talk about I did appreciate that
this episode tackled how those involved
and not involved see things John Hannah
is really the actor whose character
brings the conflict and we discover that
he also suspected the truth of the
murders as well turns out that he spent
a night with Jenna and Kenneth and
realizing that they got carried away
with the sex games made him start to
suspect I might be rich but I kind of
view this as the silent onlooker in a
lot of situations when people get
exposed people often have their
suspicions or they feel the other people
are too powerful to take down
single-handedly and this it takes a lot
of people to do it now according to the
story Davis's dad Kenneth was shot in
the shoulder and in the hospital he got
MRSA this killed him over time and this
Janet blames Ian which yeah we'll get
into now she still has a fun collection
of the crimes including the mask that
she used to wear when carrying out the
murders there's also tapes and tapes of
burgerac show that they taped elbow when
filming the crimes in the end though
when she's caught it seems Generac she
wants people to know and it's said that
serial killers often desire being caught
so that their work can be seen by the
world if no one knows about it then it's
robbing them at the notoriety and this
is why Jenna leaves the tapes to her son
after taking her life she makes a joke
when Davis says that his dad's camera
wasn't filming for broadcast and you can
say imagine because she knows what the
world would think if they actually saw
the tapes also I guess it's kinda sweet
that she leaves the tapes for her son
and writes a little note as she wants
his film to do well it's like go on son
I hope everything works out with it
which which is a bit has a bit of a dark
sense of humor to it she's just a nice
mum I guess or maybe a complete
psychopath now after the crash Pier goes
to the house on her own and this is
where she ends up discovering the truth
and what's potentially a reference to
Myra hinley and Ian Brady she has to act
normal after realizing the truth the
pair were a killer couple as well and a
friend walked in on them carrying out a
murder which is when he had to act like
it was normal due to being fearful for
his own life he went along with it then
contacted the police which led to their
arrest though Myra wasn't initially
brought in she was complicit just like
Janet and when I heard the name Ian Adar
I did start to think whether that was
playing on Ian Brady and Myra hindley
might be a reach that though but just
something I've discussed with the team
when we've been watching this episode
now upon being discovered Janna goes
after Pierre but she flees into the
night and evades capture however she
slips and bangs her head on a rock and
the characters killed at this point now
Janet then returns home and she puts in
The Masks showing that this is the true
face that she wanted to be remembered
for the mask of course Echoes the bafta
one and now Davis must present another
way to the world just like his mother
they both made videos that ruined
several people's lives and again it's
sort of like poetry they rhyme and that
tops off what's another brilliant entry
and these first two episodes in the show
do such a good job of changing things at
the last minute watching the actual
documentary at the end really took
things up a level and this was a great
announcement analysis of what goes into
these sort of things it's all for fame
profit and acclaim and it may even leave
those involved wondering if they've sold
their soul anyway that closes out the
episode and obviously I'd love to hear
your thoughts on the entry in the
comments section below huge shout outs
to our partners over at the streamer.com
we've done reviews on the entire season
and definitely go check them out if you
want to see more of our guys thoughts on
the show if you want to support the
channel for as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below and as a tank you'll get early
access to videos every week you also
have our merch store over at
xerodation.com which sells lots of
nerdian spy t-shirts hats and more you
just launched a secret Invasion slash
Pulp Fiction inspired t-shirt so if you
want to head over there and help us out
then the links in the description if you
want something else to watch make sure
you check our Jonas offer breakdown
which will be linked on screen right now
by the way huge thank you for saying to
the video Albany host Paul and I'll see
you next time take care peace